après une telle tempête
charline se demande bien comment elle va
extirper sa voiture de la neige
heureusement une déneigeuse arrive enfin
pour dégager sa rue mais en passant trop
près de la voiture elle endommage le
pare choc le conducteur de la déneigeuse
reconnaît sa faute et rassure charline
elles n'ont qu'à contacter la
municipalité pour être indemnisé et
lorsque charline appelle la ville elle
est reçue plutôt froidement on refuse à
dédommager parce que c'est le principe
de l'indemnisation direct qui s'applique
selon ce principe lors d'une collision
entre deux véhicules
chaque conducteur est indemnisé par son
propre assureur au pays
le principe de l'indemnisation direct
est appliquée dans six provinces
si vous n'êtes pas responsables vous ne
payez pas de franchise mais si vous
faites une réclamation votre prime elle
pourrait augmenter le fin mot de
l'histoire
même si c'est la ville qui responsables
de la collision
vous ne pouvez pas pelleter votre
réclamation dans sa cour